[Music]
on this Friday night Family Ties fresh
admissions about the links between the
federal housing Minister's office and a
food marketing firm did the minister
know that they were sisters
allegations the Alberta premier's office
interfered in the justice system the
demands for an investigation copyright
fight there's no recourse for me
protecting and preserving the
intellectual property of indigenous
artists and blind ambition I don't want
to let a disability stop me
picture-perfect snapshots from the eyes
of visually impaired photographers
foreign
assar reporting tonight
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight with a follow-up to our
reporting and some new details about a
federal cabinet minister and some
potentially questionable behavior in
awarding government contracts housing
Minister Ahmed Hussein stirred up
controversy last year over Revelations
he awarded a 133 thousand dollar Grant
to a group whose senior consultant made
anti-semitic comments online fast
forward to this week he's facing
questions for 93 thousand dollars worth
of government contracts given to a food
marketing agency with lackluster
qualifications in politics Mackenzie
gray joins us from Ottawa and McKenzie
you've learned of yet another personal
relationship between The Minister's
office and someone at that agency
while nithu the housing minister is in
more hot water tonight after it turns
out there is a close personal connection
with the food focused PR firm that he
hired to do Communications work for him
because if you start crying if this is
Tia Tariq ahmadusan's current policy
director and a close advisor who's
worked for him since at least 2017. her
sister is Hiba Tariq the owner of
munchmore media which is global news
first reported Thursday received 14
different contracts between January 2021
and September 2022 to do PR work for
Hussein's constituency office the bill
over ninety three thousand dollars which
represents 14 percent of who sends
entire constituency budget for that
period that means Tia was working for
Hussein when her sister was getting paid
prior to our first report we asked The
Minister's office Point Blank did
Hussein have a personal relationship
with anyone at munchmore media his
office didn't address the question it
wasn't until late Thursday night when
Global News approached his office once
again that they admitted to the
connection
The Minister's director of policy is
Miss Tia Tariq and she does have a
connection to miss Heba trick and that
connection is their sisters
did the minister know that they were
sisters
defense they spoke to the ethics
commissioner and Mario diont cleared
Hussein to hire his policy director's
sister much more media normally works
with chefs and food bloggers and they
claim to know the upcoming food industry
Trends but that Focus didn't stop
another cabinet minister from also
hiring them women and gender equality
Minister Marcy Ian used constituency
funds to bring on Hiba Tariq in March
and July of 2021 paying her a total of
ten thousand dollars we have liberal
ministers who are lining up insiders to
get access to these sweetheart contracts
that everyday Canadians would only be
too happy to have access to Ian's press
secretary says the minister didn't know
about the relationship between his son's
office and Munch more media before she
hired the pr firm that specializes in
the food industry but with those two
additional contracts need to it brings
the total amount the company was able to
earn from Liberal cabinet ministers to
over a hundred and three thousand
dollars
and Mackenzie you mentioned Hussein's
office says they were cleared by the
ethics commissioner did the ethics
commissioner confirm he spoke to son no
they didn't either the office rarely
confirms any private conversation the
commissioner has with MPS or staff for
that matter but that office did confirm
that conflict of interest rules apply at
the constituency level which means we
could see opposition parties right to
the commissioner to try and get him to
probe the issue further and we've also
heard from a number of frustrated
liberals who are quite upset with
Hussein MPS and staffers have been
reaching out to us all day saying that
Hussein should have known this was
inappropriate to give a contract to a
longtime staffer sister
Mackenzie gray in Ottawa thanks
Mackenzie
another politician facing criticism
tonight Alberta's Premier new
allegations have surfaced that a member
of her staff tried to influence Crown
prosecutors the allegations came to
light in a CBC news report which claimed
someone from Danielle Smith's office
sent a series of emails challenging
Crown prosecutors assessment of cases
stemming from the Coots border blockade
in early 2022 Smith denies any knowledge
of emails but as Heather urac's West
explains this isn't the first allegation
of political interference around
covid-19 charges involving Alberta's
premier
for 18 days in the blistering cold last
winter protesters occupied part of the
highway near the Canada U.S border at
Coots Alberta they were angry about
covid-19 measures and according to Crown
prosecutors some of those involved broke
the law four people were charged with
conspiracy to murder police officers 13
with weapons offenses and three people
accused of organizing the protests were
charged with Mischief have asked them to
consider all charges under the lens of
is it in the public interest to pursue
and is there a reasonable likelihood of
conviction in a series of interviews and
media appearances since mid-December
Alberta's Premier said she spoke to
prosecutors about whether criminal cases
related to covert restrictions should
proceed comments that set off a
firestorm of criticism then a
clarification comes out and says no she
never called Crown prosecutors that
would be wrong no one would ever do that
but I did speak to
the attorney general and the deputy
attorney general but according to
reporting by CBC that Global News has
not been able to independently verify a
staff member within the premier's office
sent a series of emails to the Alberta
Crown prosecution service last fall
challenging its assessment and direction
of the cases stemming from the Coots
border blockades she certainly was
sympathetic to the protesters at Coots
so it's it's not surprising that she and
the people around her would be
interested in what was happening to
those prosecutions in a statement the
premier's office denied any knowledge of
the emails calling the allegations
serious if true warranting appropriate
action Alberta's opposition NDP renewed
calls for an independent investigation
failing to do so and allowing this chaos
to stand will cause profound damage to
the rule of law in Alberta an Alberta
Crown prosecution service spokesperson
says they have no recollection of
receiving emails from the premier's
office
last week a mischief and weapons charge
against one of the accused in the Coots
border blockade was withdrawn by the
crown Heather urik's West Global News
Calgary
an investigation into what led to a
police shootout with suspects at a bank
in British Columbia last year revealed
some chilling details police say the
twin brothers from Vancouver Island
acted alone had an arsenal of weapons
and were motivated by a hatred for
police it was a Brazen daylight attack
six officers were shot all survived but
five are still off work Paul Johnson was
at today's briefing as the findings of
the investigation were made public Paul
nietzsu police believe that this was the
vision of two isolated loners who hated
police hated government and for years
had been planning to carry out some kind
of major attack where they would kill as
many police as possible and would die in
the process police believe the
22-year-old twins Isaac and Matthew
octoloni not only carried out the attack
by themselves but for years had been
planning and stockpiling their Arsenal
also by themselves the weapons they used
and the ammo was all acquired legally
though they did make some illegal
modifications to their rifles which were
SKS semi-automatics very common in
Canada police believe they chose this
Bank in sanish randomly with the purpose
not of stealing any money but using the
holdout to draw police into a shooter
fortunately for the police and all of
the innocent people who were involved a
SWAT team had been deployed nearby to a
completely unrelated incident when this
happened so when the octolonies got
their shootout with police it was with
heavily armed officers trained just for
a situation like this this is an event
that we will never forget
that said it is important how we choose
to remember June 28 2022
at Saanich
we are encouraging our officers and
staff to remember this day is one that
innocent lives were protected and saved
by police officers we also learned a
little bit more about the Octor loans
apparently they had been living with
their mother they both worked at the
same job in light manufacturing and
police believe they'd actually been
planning this attack for 2023 but
decided they had to move it up to last
June because they were forced to move
house and they were worried that in the
process of moving somebody might
discover this Arsenal that they've been
building up and call police
nichu back to you
Paul Johnson in Saanich BC thanks Paul
the federal government is hoping to
capitalize on Canada's vast geography
and space expertise to become a global
player in commercial space launches it's
fired up a plan to authorize satellite
launches within the next three years as
Eric Sorensen reports it's a new
frontier that will bring Canada's work
in Space full circle
Canada has put astronauts in space
satellites in space some of the highest
technological advances in space what it
has not done is this
Canada has never been home to launching
Rockets into space and that's going to
change we have a strong space ecosystem
here in Canada and this was one of the
missing links Ottawa is going to bring
in regulations to launch spacecraft from
Canada including interim approvals to
get the commercial industry off the
ground quickly this is an important
piece for us to have an end-to-end space
sector we're now going to be able to
launch commercially here in Canada which
is going to play such an important role
near cancel Nova Scotia on the East
Coast Maritime launch Services is
already an early development of a
Spaceport just outside of town the
company hopes to launch a small
sub-orbital craft this year and have a
full facility to launch scores of
satellites within three years we want to
launch eight or ten times a year and be
able to put five tons into orbit so we
can put you know 25 or 31 web satellites
on one Mission at a time that's where
the market share is that's where the
market need is right now Canada is a
vast potential launch pad into space for
safety and Technical reasons spacecraft
from Cape Canaveral only launch in
easterly directions over the Atlantic
cancel Nova Scotia is at a different
latitude and could launch more southerly
routes also safely over the ocean one or
more spaceports in Canada would offer
commercial launch sites and new orbital
Pathways for satellites above the Earth
we can offer a lot of high inclination
orbits which is very much in demand for
Earth observation and other specific
applications so it's an ideal country
from that point of view eventually
astronauts may fly from Canada but the
priority now is the satellite business
it means we're open for business so
we've got tremendous capabilities in
robotics construction design engineering
and coming soon the final Canadian Link
in that chain Transportation into space
we always felt like we were part of the
space World space Community this is
maybe like the last feather in our cap
Eric Sorensen Global News Toronto
to the war in Ukraine no deal was made
today at defense talks focusing on
whether to send german-made tanks to
Ukraine Germany is facing intense
pressure from allies to send leopard to
tanks many countries own them but
Germany has veto power over any tank
exports and appears reluctant to
authorize delivery unless the U.S does
the same Ukraine's President says his
troops need more help now
a reality check on sustainability coming
up why Canada's shift to electric
vehicles is easier said than done
the Prime Minister traveled across the
country this week visiting electric
vehicle plans as part of the Liberals
push to make Canada a major EV player
the government wants 20 percent of all
new vehicles purchased in Canada to be
electric by 2026 but as Taria is
re-reports some urban planners say this
transition may not be as green as we
think
this red Tesla is the only electric
vehicle on the Block but if Canada's
plan to accelerate the EV Revolution
goes ahead there will be many more
beautiful Raymond Lurie was an early
convert to the sleeker silent
alternative buying his first 10 years
ago I wanted to have a zero emission
vehicle and uh so I jumped on the van
away again very early
the federal government has also jumped
on the bandwagon in a big Way
Ottawa wants one-fifth of new vehicles
to be electric by 2026. the Target is 60
percent by 2030 and a hundred percent in
2035 meaning all vehicles sold in Canada
will run on electricity in less than a
decade to get fossil fuels off the road
it takes time to ramp up in terms of
charging infrastructure manufacturing
capability getting battery factories
built prime minister Justin Trudeau
spent the week touring these
manufacturing plants we need to make
sure we're building up a world-leading
ecosystem in North America he stopped by
a lithium mine project
a key ingredient in
Urban emitted from producing an electric
vehicle is significantly higher than
emitted from producing an internal
combustion vehicle and that has to do
with battery manufacturing Waste
Management experts say those emissions
are offset over time but there are other
concerns EVS are not cheap and for
people who live in apartments without
charging stations powering them up may
not be easy or even possible electric
vehicles are kind of talked about in
Canada as the final step whereas in in
Europe they're very much talked about as
a stepping stone to save the planet
urban planner Jason Slaughter believes
more Canadians need to go car free in
entirely
if you can get even a tiny fraction of
the number of people who are currently
driving onto other modes of Transit like
walking cycling or public transit then
you can offset huge numbers of electric
cars I mean it's so much better
Larry also wants more public transit but
says it's not a reliable way to get
around his neighborhood and so many
others in Canada and if you look at the
climate crisis it's a you know we've got
to do stuff short term
[Music]
are betting on the Eevee boom teria esri
Global News
Ottawa
ahead the push to protect indigenous
intellectual property
[Music]
the protection of indigenous language
stories songs poems and other forms of
cultural expression has been front and
center this week at a National
Conference a First Nations artist in BC
says it took a cease and desist order
for an offshore company to stop using
her work without permission she helps
explain why the issue goes beyond
copyright infringement
my English name is Luanne Neal and I'm
from the mama Lila and the quagle people
from wood carvings and painted Works to
textiles and jewelry Luanne Neal has
been creating original designs for more
than 30 years our Visual Arts are are
directly connected to dance and music
and spirituality and our cultural
practices she says for indigenous
artists like her who create commercially
significant training around cultural
protocols and family connections passed
down through generations is required
these are part and parcel of all of our
histories right back to our Origins
which is why it's such a blow when their
work is exploited Neil says these two
designs of hers were taken by an
offshore company last year with her name
removed and sold on t-shirts only taken
down weeks later after multiple requests
and a seize and assist letter there's no
recourse for me I you know it would cost
me more money to hire a lawyer to sue
them than it would for any returns I'd
get back from that Neil has long been
advocating for organizations in Canada
which specifically support indigenous
artists she spoke at a national
gathering this week focused on data
sovereignty hosted by the office of
special interlocutor Kimberly Murray
indigenous data indigenous knowledge
indigenous stories songs lands Waters
practices have been collected for
inappropriate purposes
in the case of stainless Nation about
100 kilometers east of Vancouver one of
the most important symbols looked upon
for Generations as having spirit Power
has been widely appropriated the
Sasquatch means so much to us as a
people a story they say was stolen by a
government agent in the 1920s and has
been misused ever since the Sasquatch is
even our logo and that's how that's how
dear he is to our heart we're really
proud of who we are proud of where we
come from we're proud of what we belong
to and we always want to take care of
all of that First Nations Inuit and
metis cultures have been appropriated by
sports teams fashion designers companies
and governments for decades those calls
to action from The Truth and
Reconciliation Commission were not calls
to action just for businesses for media
for lawyers for Education it was calls
to action each and every one of Canadian
we're the ones who invented it it
belongs to us and some of those working
to retell their misused stories are
highlighting the role every Canadian
plays in doing that work
next the UK photography club with a
unique vision
a photography club in England is
capturing the beauty of the world
through a unique lens its members are
all visually impaired but as Crystal
commencing Reports their talent is
crystal clear
gosport offers photographers a bit of
everything history scenery and nature
I've set my camera up this time to take
pictures of seagulls so when I see one
I'm all ready to go so you got it all
good to go from birth Andrew Fletcher
has been blind in his right eye and has
limited Vision in his left whenever I
pick up a camera I always have to
photograph a bird because I enjoy the
challenge of trying to and follow a bird
in Flight don't have it always bangs out
in the middle Dave Taylor formed the
below 2020 media Club a charity
supported group the name is a nod to
their visual impairments Taylor loves
helping others take pictures as much as
he loves snapping them himself and that
sort of threw the trees and the sunlight
in the shadow Sue Rob has retinitis
Pigmentosa and says the little up close
Vision she has left will eventually be
lost at the library in Ferrum the club's
work is getting a lot of attention
I feel quite proud in a sense of
achievement for the show the
photographers were tasked with picking
two photos to display while this is
England Canada is featured specifically
Canmore
this one in particular
got me because the bench I can see
myself sitting there with a flask of
coffee cheese sandwich and just looking
out there and just taking in what's
going on I've called it peace and
Tranquility creating something and
sharing it with the world takes courage
I find it as a bit of a challenge and I
don't want to let a disability stop me I
feel like my eyesight is given to me
again like I'm born again and take
pictures so I can see the world in a
different way Elena Summers radiates
life when talking about photography the
power of the lens is clear and the club
hopes to do more but it comes down to
funding and while the Snaps are
Limitless the dollars aren't
Crystal commencing Global News
gosport England
and one of those images is tonight's
your Canada Dave Taylor took this shot
near Kenmore Alberta that's global
national for this Friday night thanks
for watching
[Music]